je suis ici à caen de saint martin en
indre et loire l'un des plus beaux
villages de france qui abrite le château
de mots cet endroit formidable offre
résidence à des artistes street art qui
en ont fait un véritable musée urbain à
ciel ouvert rencontre avec monique et
didier les propriétaires du lieu qui ne
manquent pas d'imagination
le château de mots j'en perds mes mots
oui parce que ça provoque beaucoup
d'émotion oui je sais que les
propriétaires des lieux m le slam
bonjour monique bonjour didier bonjour à
midi il ya moyen de faire le tour du
propriétaire en voiture est un peu moins
joué c'est monique didier à tout à
l'heure un peu c'est parti monique
monique mon guide alors qu'elle oeuvre
voulait me montrer là on commence par
quoi la part les portes de métro se sont
authentiques portes de métro de la ligne
attendez laissez moi j'imagine je lui
sors du métro parisien sans du métro de
sueur du métro paf tu arrives dans les
bois
surtout val de loire et sur le quai en
face à la loi et voilà tu sors du métro
tu ta la loire juste en face franchement
c'est je préfère ce métro là j'ai
rajouté ma tête de dents là je suis je
suis
petit poucet
spa didier ça
et il y aura encore d'autres choses un
élégant c'est mardi
[Musique]
ça c'est dans lé cadre de notre hommage
à marcel duchamp
c'est vrai ça représente bien la
campagne
les chants et par conséquent j'ai ma
place dans l'oeuvre moi qui fais du rap
de campagne
c'était mon moment à moi là didier
c'était mon tour
décrivez moi un petit peu cette oeuvre
de la reine qu'est ce qui m'attend bon
déjà la reine c'est une cet espace
seront là que vous voyez là personne ne
connaît l'origine personne ne peut la
dater alors on a testé un petit peu
l'acoustique de la reine attention c'est
parti o o man show qu au
tu es le plus beau des chocs oh
oh oh le choc tout le mot
oui le choc on au
motif qu'on peut dire que c'est une
arène qui pousse l'artiste à l'humilité
parce que dans tous les cas tu sort par
la petite porte
c'est l'humilité ça le fameux gorille
est oui dessiné par l'espion ces cinq
espions espions montre à y arriver de
montreuil ouais d'accord et une vitesse
de travail impressionnante également sa
cellule appelée c'est du programmé tant
à une oeuvre comme celle là il faisait
très chaud il a fait il a fait ça entre
une fin de journée c'était le lendemain
matin pratiquement way affrontés il ya
un oeil là
espionné par espions partout céline
dubois
didier
monde voit ton oeil chaque année et des
nouvelles offres vous changer tous les
ans les autres c'est comme en grandes
lettres on complète en fait à eau qu'on
rajoute les oreilles absolument créer
une résidence chaque année un avis des
artistes qui restent en résidence on les
nourrit on les loge on fait la fête avec
eux ont créé avec eux pourquoi le momu
dont château de mots une référence à
monique en même temps on peut décliner
justement morizet c'est un jeunot et
bien monique et didier merci merci pour
cette balade merci pour ce choc temporel
entre le 18e et le 20e siècle merci
merci pour ça et je ne sais pas encore
une belle histoire d'amour l'amour
éternel